Einstein showed that if you watch me as
I'm walking you will say that time
elapsed is more slowly on my watch than
it does on your watch time slows for an
object in motion now that blows your
mind because it's so counterintuitive
you've never experienced that the reason
simply is that you've never experienced
speeds near the speed of light where
these effects become big and obvious so
the question is for us lowly human
beings that don't travel near the speed
of light is there a mental mnemonic some
sort of intuitive way of thinking about
why it is that time slows down when an
object is in motion and there is and it
makes use of a little metaphor that at
first sight has nothing to do with time
or any of these ideas just imagine that
we have say an SUV and that SUV is
traveling at a hundred kilometers per
hour purely in the northward direction
then we imagine changing the situation
slightly by having that same SUV also
going 100 km/h but now in a north
easterly direction and the point I want
you to grasp is a simple one which is
simply this because part of the cars
motion has now been diverted from north
to east its speed in the northward
direction has slowed down and therefore
it hasn't traveled as far north as this
car and indeed if we consider a car
that's traveling even more toward the
east
it's diverting even more of its original
motion toward the north into eastward
motion so it travels even less distance
in the northward direction compared to
the car that's moving purely toward the
north simple idea why is it relevant
well this notion actually has a version
that applies to time and here's how it
goes you'll
see it sounds very similar right now I'm
standing still and you say I'm not
moving but if you really think in
space-time terms you realize I am moving
through time right my watch if I had one
is ticking second after second after
second making me move through time all
of my motion therefore is purely in the
time direction now if I start to walk
Einstein showed that my motion through
space diverts some of my previous motion
through time into that motion through
space and therefore my motion through
time slows down just like the motion
toward the north of these cars slows
down too because that motion has been
diverted into a different direction in
this case it's diverting a spatial
motion in one direction to a spatial
motion another direction in the
interesting relativistic case it's my
motion through time that's now being
diverted into motion through space so my
motion through time slows down and
that's an intuitive way of understanding
why it is that when an object is in
motion time for it compared to you will
elapse more slowly